es darf sich hier recht herzlich
begrüßen auf der Feuerwache 51 auf der
Feuerwache hier in Neukölln und wir
hatten heute ein Gespräch mit der
bundesinnenministerin mit der
regierenden Bürgermeisterin und der
innensenatorin und den
Bezirksbürgermeister hier vom Bezirk
Neukölln und zwar ein Gespräch zu den
Erkenntnissen und Erfahrungen die wir
als Berliner Feuerwehr machen mussten
mit den Ereignissen in der
Silvesternacht des Jahreswechsels 22 23
sie alle kennen glaube ich die
Erkenntnis und die Erfahrungen die ja
auch entsprechend kommuniziert wurden
wir haben heute die Gelegenheit genutzt
um uns mit Einsatzkräften auch zu
unterhalten die in meiner Wahrnehmung
sehr ergreifend auch geschildert haben
dass wir eine völlig neue Dimension
haben eine völlig neue Dimension hier
was Angriffe auf Einsatzkräfte angeht
eine Dimension die sich in der
Silvesternacht auch des Instruments
natürlich der Feuerwerksraketen und
Pyrotechnik bedient haben und eine neue
Dimension bin der Gestalt dass unsere
Einsatzkräfte sehr anschaulich und auch
sehr ergreifend berichtet haben wie wir
teilweise man muss es schon sagen in
Hinterhalte auch gelockt worden sind wir
als Feuerwehr und dann ganz gezielt
angegriffen worden sind und das etwas
ist was wirklich die neue Qualität auch
darstellt wir haben ja darüber auch
berichtet dass wir eine Vielzahl von
Angriffen dokumentiert haben wir haben
noch am 1.1 morgens um 6 Uhr schon
berichtet über insgesamt 38 Angriffe auf
Einheiten der Feuerwehr und der
Hilfsorganisation im Rahmen der
Nacherfassung weil wir viele Partner
haben und auch das Ehrenamt sind wir
jetzt schon bei über 50 wir haben 15
verletzte Angehörige des
Rettungsdienstes und der Feuerwehr auch
das ist etwas was eine neue Dimension
darstellt und wir haben sogar eine
Einsatzkraft die im Krankenhaus
behandelt werden musste und sie sehen
nicht nur das Ergebnis sondern auch das
was wir hier mit wem wir konfrontiert
worden waren ist eine ganz besondere
neue Dimension und mir ist noch mal
wichtig auch an dieser Stelle auch
unseren ganzen Einsatzkräften Dank zu
sagen Danke für das Geleistete in der
Silvesternacht danke dass Sie in gewehrt
haben Art und Weise als Feuerwehren wie
wir es gewohnt sind auch mit den
mit den unbekannten lagen entsprechend
dort umgegangen sind und sie auch
professionell bewältigt haben mir ist es
auch wichtig in diesem Dank auch
ausdrücklich darzulegen dass es 1500
Einsatzkräfte waren aus den
unterschiedlichsten Organisationen die
mit diesem Phänomen mit diesen
Übergriffen konfrontiert wurden das
waren nicht nur Feuerwehrkräfte sondern
auch Angehörige der Hilfsorganisation
und des technischen hilfswertes und es
waren im großen Umfang auch
ehrenamtliche Angehörige und das ist das
was mich ganz besonders auch ärgert dass
es Menschen die in dieser Stadt bereit
sind hier im Rahmen ihres Ehrenamtes
freiwillig in ihrem eigenen Zeitbudget
sich einzusetzen für die Sicherheit
dieser Gesellschaft dann auch hier
konfrontiert werden mit einer
ausufernden Gewalt mit diesen
Erkenntnissen und mit diesen Dingen die
wir sammeln mussten und auch darüber
haben wir uns ausgetauscht auch hier
haben wir sehr eindrucksvoll auch aus
der aus den Reihen der Freiwilligen
Feuerwehr gehört und die Schilderung
wahrnehmen müssen was in dieser Nacht
passiert ist und als Landesbranddirektor
und Leiter der Berliner Feuerwehr möchte
ich auch hier zum Ausdruck bringen und
ich glaube das können Sie alle
nachvollziehen das macht etwas mit uns
das macht etwas auch mit unseren
Einsatzkräften und unsere Einsatzkräfte
und da kann ich ihnen berichten dass
gestandene Einsatzleiter die seit vielen
Jahrzehnten im Dienst bei der Berliner
Feuerwehr sind und das ist kein
einfacher Dienst das können Sie mir
glauben die ist gewohnt sind auch in
problembehafteten Bereichen tätig zu
werden dass die uns erstmalig berichtet
haben teilweise kurz vor der Pension sie
haben das erste mal Angst gehabt Angst
in dieser Situation Angst vor der
Bedrohung Angst vor den Auswirkungen die
eventuell jetzt auf sie eintreffen und
ich kann Ihnen sagen wer in Berlin
Dienst tut und das wäre Jahrzehnte lang
der hat schon viel erlebt den für den
sollte das Thema Angst eigentlich wenn
überhaupt anders gelegt sein als durch
Übergriffe auf Einsatzkräfte und sie
können sich vorstellen die ganzen großen
Ereignisse die die Feuerwehr bewältigt
hat in den vielen letzten Jahrzehnten
glaube ich zeig die Dimension in der für
uns auch hier bewegen und insofern bin
ich dankbar dass auch meine Kolleginnen
und Kollegen so offen auch heute
angesprochen haben was ihnen Angst
bereitet ich möchte aber auch zum
Ausdruck bringen dass das auch mir als
Landesbranddirektor schon im Rahmen der
Fürsorge auch wichtig ist darüber zu
reden und auch anzuerkennen und
festzustellen dass wir auch hier dort in
einer Nachbetreuung auch ein Stück weit
sind es macht nämlich insbesondere
psychisch etwas mit einem und insofern
war dieses Gespräch auch ein
wesentlicher Baustein auch für die
Bewältigung dieser Lage wir haben aber
als Berliner Feuerwehr allen Beteiligten
auch angeboten am nächsten Dienstag dort
im Rahmen einer Einsatzkräfte Nachsorge
sich auch einzubringen und wir werden
auch das ganze Instrumentarium was wir
als Dienste anbieten können auch jetzt
in den Einsatz bringen und das Angebot
ist schon aktiv unterbreitet das ist mir
einfach wichtig an dieser Stelle viel
wichtiger sind aber die Botschaften die
gleich sicherlich auch aus dem
politischen Raum dann gesendet werden
können weil schon meine Forderung so bin
ich jetzt mal etwas direkt schon sind
dass es sich sowas nicht wiederholen
darf und dass wir jetzt Entscheidungen
brauchen wir brauchen jetzt
Entscheidungen es darf so nicht
weitergehen wir brauchen jetzt
Entscheidungen die auch schon wirken
beim nächsten Silvester nämlich
Silvester 23 24 und wir haben uns alle
darüber unterhalten über
dort Dinge die da passiert sind und
unsere Wünsche und unsere Bitten sind
natürlich die dass wir mit vielen
einzelnen Maßnahmen die wir jetzt zu
starten haben über die es natürlich zu
diskutieren gilt die zu entscheiden sind
dann auch in die wirkphase eintreten
können manche wirkphasen sind erst im
geraumer Zeit aber hier brauchen wir
ganz konkret Dinge die auch schon
hier brauchen wir auch Entscheidungen
und Dinge die dann schon beim nächsten
Silvester wirken und das war meine Bitte
und auch die bitte meiner Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Feuerwehrangehörigen
hier in Berlin an die Politik an die
politische Verantwortlichen in dieser
Stadt aber auch in der Bundesrepublik
insofern danke schön dass Sie da sind
und ich übergebe jetzt das Mikrofon
vielen Dank Herr homburghausen meine
Damen und Herren wenn
gestandene Feuerwehrleute die wirklich
hier in den Innenstadt lagen Neukölln
Kreuzberg Wedding seit Jahrzehnten ihren
Dienst zu nennen gestandene Polizei
Kräfte die wirklich hier mit allen
weiteren gewaschen sind sagen so etwas
haben sie in dieser Form noch nicht
erlebt dann haben wir hier eine Zäsur
die ganz klar heißen muss das Ende der
Geduld ist mehr als überschritten hier
sind wirklich Grenzen überschritten
worden von Respektlosigkeit und
Brutalität die ihresgleichen suchen und
das bedeutet dass wir miteinander
Landesebene Bezirksebene Bundesebene
nicht nur darüber beraten müssen sondern
sehr schnell ins Handeln kommen müssen
was die Frage der Reaktion auf diese
Ereignisse angeht was die Frage der
Konsequenzen angeht und ich bin sehr
froh dass wir heute hier Bezirk Land und
Bund Liebe Nancy Feser vielen Dank dass
Sie gekommen sind als Innenministerin
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland dass wir
hier ganz klar auch sehen diese
Ereignisse die wir bei uns gesehen haben
die hat es nicht nur in Berlin gegeben
der hat es in der ganzen Bundesrepublik
gegeben aber hier sind sie in besonderer
Intensität auch zum Vorschein gekommen
und das ist und so haben es die Kollegen
auch berichtet die Spitze eines Eisbergs
es ist die Gewalt Entladung an einem
Abend an dem bestimmte Gruppen das für
legitim gehalten haben
aber es ist auch ein Werteverfall eine
Respektlosigkeit die an allen anderen
Tagen sichtbar wird und das sehen die
Kollegen die hier auch nach der
Silvesternacht in den Tagen bedroht und
angegriffen worden sind die immer in
einer Ausnahmesituation ihren Einsatz
denken und planen und umsetzen müssen
und wir haben hier ganz klar die
Notwendigkeit auf allen Ebenen
eine konsequente Strafverfolgung jetzt
durchzusetzen da Strafmaß ist vorhanden
es muss umgesetzt werden es ist die
Justiz sie jetzt auch in der
Verantwortung ist es ist die Polizei die
jetzt in den intensiven Ermittlungen ist
wir haben
umfangreiches Videomaterial wir haben
umfangreiche Beweismittel wir kennen die
Täter teilweise weil wir sie aus dem
Kiez kennen und es ist so dass wir ein
umfangreiches Set an Maßnahmen brauchen
um jetzt damit umzugehen Strafverfolgung
ist das eine die Ausrüstung und
Ausstattung und Aufstockung unserer
Einsatzkräfte von Polizei und Feuerwehr
ist das zweite das ist ein Thema wo ihre
Spranger auch gleich drauf eingehen wird
das dritte ist eine auch bundesweite
Debatte über Notwendigkeiten angesetztes
Änderungen in der Innenministerkonferenz
in den Gesprächen die jetzt notwendig
sind was muss bundesweit anders laufen
in Deutschland
aber es ist auch was können wir hier tun
über die Strafverfolgung hinaus und ich
bin gestern hier den ganzen Tag auch
unterwegs gewesen habe mit vielen
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern gesprochen mit
den Einsatzkräften aber auch mit den
Menschen die jeden Tag in den
Jugendeinrichtungen arbeiten auch mit
Jugendlichen selbst
wir sehen dass wir hier offensichtlich
junge Menschen haben die nicht mehr in
dem Maße sich einer Gesellschaft
zugehörig fühlen und sich verpflichtet
fühlen dem Respekt gegenüber
Einsatzkräften
was wir als normal betrachten würden und
das ist ernst zu nehmen das ist auch in
dem gesamten Gefüge der brennpunktlagen
zu sehen wir haben die Taten die Erfolg
sind sind überall in brennpunktlagen
erfolgt sind in Lagen Erfolg wo wir seit
Jahren Probleme haben wo wir seit Jahren
auch investieren wo wir seit Jahren
Sozialarbeit haben und dennoch ist es
passiert und das bedeutet dass wir
unseren Umgang damit verändern müssen
und das bedeutet dass wir deutlich
konsequenter werden müssen in den Folgen
die das hat aber auch dass wir mit denen
die jeden Tag hier zusammenarbeiten in
der Jugendsozialarbeit in den Schulen in
der Elternarbeit darüber sprechen müssen
was braucht es dazu um jetzt zu agieren
und das bedeutet ein konsequenter
Rechtsstaat bei gleichzeitig den
Notwendigkeiten die es braucht damit
diese Jugendlichen wieder zurückfinden
in einen normales Verhältnis zu Staat
und Gesellschaft und in einen
respektvollen Umgang mit Einsatzkräften
und mit denen die hier diesen Staat
vertreten und das bedeutet eine
gemeinsame Anstrengung die notwendig ist
auf allen Ebenen zusätzliche
Investitionen zusätzliche Ausstattung
und ein klares Bekenntnis dazu dass
diese Taten nicht ohne Folgen bleiben
und da sind wir uns hier sehr einig sehr
einig auf Bezirks auf Landes auf
Bundesebene und wir werden im nächsten
Senat auch darüber beraten nächste Woche
Dienstag wir werden nächste Woche einen
Gipfel haben zum Thema Jugendgewalt zum
Thema Umgang mit Jugendgewalt hier in
Berlin mit den Akteuren die daran
arbeiten und darüber sprechen welche
Maßnahmen müssen jetzt ergriffen werden
damit wir hier
ganz klar ein Ziel auch erfüllen so ein
Silvester darf es nicht noch einmal
geben und das mit allen Kräften
zu vollziehen die dafür notwendig sind
es jetzt unsere Aufgabe und es ist
wichtig dass das nicht nur eine
strohfeuer-diskussion ist kurz nach
Silvester und dann ist er wieder alles
wie immer sondern dass wir wirklich
gezielt Maßnahmen ergreifen die über das
Jahr hinweg wirken und dann auch in die
schweren Tage 1 Mai Halloween und
Silvester vorbereitet reingehen mit
allen Kräften und mit der klaren
Rückendeckung für Polizei Feuerwehr die
Einsatzkräfte das ist auch wichtig dass
Sie wissen wir stehen voll hinter ihnen
und sie bekommen alles was Sie brauchen
damit sie handlungsfähig sind damit sie
geschützt sind damit sie einsatzfähig
sind
vielleicht so weit und jetzt vielen Dank
an die bundesinnenministerin dass sie
hier ist
[Musik]
ja meine Damen und Herren vielen Dank
dass Sie gekommen sind ich darf mich bei
der regierenden Bürgermeisterin bedanken
auch beim landesbrandinspektor dass ich
heute hier zu Gast sein darf mir war es
wichtig meine Wertschätzung und meinen
Dank an die Einsatzkräfte die in der
silvestern nach dem Einsatz waren
auszudrücken an die hauptberufliche
Feuerwehr aber auch an die Freiwillige
Feuerwehr die dort auch im Einsatz waren
das Phänomen der das mangelnden Respekt
des Gegenüber Einsatzkräften ist nicht
neu ich will das nur noch mal sagen weil
wir das ja auch schon Monate
zuvor thematisiert haben dass dort etwas
passieren muss dass wir wieder mehr
Respekt brauchen für das was geleistet
wird Feuerwehr ist Bestandteil fester
Bestandteil der Sicherheitsarchitektur
in Deutschland
Feuerwehrleute Kameradinnen und
Kameraden setzen sich für andere ein sie
sorgen dafür dass wir als Bürgerinnen
und Bürger Sicherheit bekommen und
deswegen verdienen Sie auch den vollen
Schutz des Staates nicht nur dass wir
hinter ihnen stehen sondern dass wir
auch handeln entsprechend zum Schutz der
Einsatzkräfte und das gilt für ganz
Deutschland wir sind heute hier in
Neukölln in einem der Schwerpunkte aber
es gibt deutschlandweit weitere wir
haben jetzt exemplarisch heute Neukölln
besucht und haben mit den entsprechenden
Kräften auch geredet mir war es wichtig
persönlich die Schilderungen aus der
Silvesternacht auch noch mal zu bekommen
und mich hat das tief beeindruckt zu
hören in welch widerlicher Art und Weise
dort von ganz jungen Tätern gehandelt
wurde dass dort gezielt Feuerwehr in
Hinterhalt
gelockt wurden um dann gezielt
beschlossen zu werden das ist wirklich
eine neue Qualität da der
landesbrandinspektor und die Regierende
Bürgermeisterin haben sie angesprochen
sehr recht das ist eine neue Art und
Weise der widerlichen Art von
Kriminalität die wir unterbinden müssen
aus meiner Sicht ist die wichtigste
aller
Bevölkerung daraus ist dass die
Jugendlichen der Linken
sofort darauf eine Reaktions spüren
nämlich eine sehr schnelle
Aburteilung und Verurteilung dass man
auch merkt der Staat ist dort
handlungsfähig und zeigt die Grenzen auf
die es hat weil das natürlich auch
Wirkung auf andere Jugendliche hat auf
die betreffenden Straftäter dass sie
merken ihr Fehlverhalten hat
Konsequenzen das halte ich für einen der
wichtigsten Punkte den wir dort auch mit
der Justiz umsetzen müssen ich habe
vorhin noch mal darüber gesprochen dass
diese jugendrechtshäuser wo
Staatsanwaltschaft wo Polizei wo auch
Jugendgerichtshilfe zusammenarbeiten um
schnelle Maßnahmen zu verhängen genau
das Richtige ist das ist in Neukölln ja
auch gemacht worden ich glaube dass man
da noch mal ran muss auch über insgesamt
in der Bundesrepublik zu gucken wo gibt
es das schon wo ist das wirkungsvoll wo
kann man das noch verstärken weil diese
direkten Konsequenzen aus meiner Sicht
sehr sehr wichtig sind das weitere ist
dass wir auf der Bundesebene an
Konsequenz ziehen werden das ist die
Verschärfung des Waffenrechtes und sie
wissen dass ich das nicht erst seit der
Silvester macht mache sondern dass wir
das vorher schon vorbereitet hat dass
ihre Spranger das jetzt als Vorsitzender
Innenministerkonferenz auch dort
eingespeist hat ist genau der richtige
Weg so geht man mit den Themen um die
bundesweit Bedeutung haben und das
betrifft nämlich auch die Verschärfung
im Umgang mit Schreckschusswaffen die in
der Silvesternacht eine große Rolle
gespielt haben bislang kann man die
erlaubnisfrei erwerben das wollen wir
jetzt ändern das habe ich in meinem
Gesetzentwurf schon drin auch vor der
Silvesternacht schon drin gehabt dass
man für den Erwerb einer Erlaubnis
braucht künftig ich halte das für
wichtig auch noch mal in der Setzung
dass es eben nicht ein harmloses
Instrument ist mit dem man an Silvester
agieren kann sondern im Gegenteil es
handelt sich um eine Waffe und dafür
braucht es eine Erlaubnis und diese
Verschärfung halte ich für auch ein
wichtiges Signal das wird das nicht
alles verändern das alles kleine Teile
die zu einem großen Ganzen gehören
natürlich fängt die Bekämpfung dieses
mangelnden Respektes gegenüber dem Staat
das fängt im Kindergärten an wir müssen
mit einer guten Sozialarbeit in
Kindergärten in Schulen die Wege dafür
bereiten wir haben vorhin darüber
gesprochen für kleine Kinder ich habe
selbst einen Sohn ist Feuerwehr das
größte das ist etwas was höchsten
Respekt hat und offensichtlich geht es
danach verloren und da müssen wir
ansetzen damit es nicht passiert sondern
damit den Jugendlichen auch klar ist was
die Einsatzkräfte leisten für ihre
eigene Sicherheit der Jugendlichen für
die Eltern der Jugendlichen sie sind
dafür da dass wenn es irgendwo brennt
dass wenn andere Gefahren vorherrschen
geholfen wird und dieses Bewusstsein in
die Jugendlichen wieder zu bekommen und
auch in die Familien das ist sehr
wichtig und ich halte einen letzten
Punkt für extrem wichtig dass man auch
anspricht um wen handelt es sich da
natürlich ist es wichtig auch zu
benennen dass die Täterinnen und Täter
es sind ja für ich glaube in ganz
überwiegender zahltäter das kann man ja
auch so benennen Jugendliche mit
Migrationshintergrund sind das zu
verschweigen ist nicht richtig aber auf
der anderen Seite ist es auch nicht
richtig dass jetzt für politische
Diskussionen zu missbrauchen weil gerade
hier in dem Kiez wie Neukölln das sind
doch gerade die Menschen die am meisten
darunter gelitten haben haben selbst
Migrationshintergrund und regen sich am
meisten darüber auf und wollen auch dass
es starke Konsequenzen im Handeln des
Staates gibt deswegen sollte man diese
Debatten nicht miteinander vermengen
immer ansprechen das ist ich glaube
darauf haben die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
auch ein Recht an die Ursachen rangehen
aber es nicht missbrauchen für
politischen Debatten das wäre aus meiner
Sicht ganz ganz wichtig dass auch
einzuhalten zum Schluss noch mal mein
herzlichen Dank nicht nur die
Feuerwehreinsatzkräfte für ihre Arbeit
und zwar ganzjährig nicht nur für die
Silvesternacht dass es viel zu kurz
gesprungen sie haben sehr schwere
Bedingungen in ihrem Gegensatz und wir
als Politik müssen dafür sorgen dass die
Rahmenbedingungen stimmen vielen Dank
ja meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
ich bin der bundesinnenministerin und
der regierenden Bürgermeisterin sehr
sehr dankbar dass sie das was wir
gesamtheitlich machen müssen in der
Bundesrepublik und hier auch in Berlin
dass sie das entsprechend mit uns im
Blick haben
es wird nicht nur darum gehen dass das
ein reines innenpolitisches Thema ist
sondern ich werde als innensenatorin und
das habe ich ja schon in diesem ersten
Jahr meines
amtsantrittes sehr deutlich auch immer
wieder gesagt und die Bundesministerin
hat es gerade auch erläutert was das
Waffengesetz angeht das heißt also wir
werden
selbstverständlich das was der
Landesbranddirektor was die Polizei
Berlin uns mitgegeben hat an sofortigen
Maßnahmen auch umsetzen sie wissen dass
die Regierende Bürgermeisterin und ich
dort an einem Strang ziehen was die
Ausrüstung angeht das heißt also die
Bitte um mehr bodycams die Bitte um die
Kameras vorne auch bei Einsätzen der
Feuerwehr wir sind Bundes Zeit das erste
Bundesland was im übrigen auch bodycams
bei Feuerwehr ausgereicht hat das heißt
also auch da waren wir schon
vor der Lage das heißt wir werden das
selbstverständlich dann auch
weitermachen und diese bodycams sind
nicht das einzige oder die Kameras
völlig klar
im Zusammenhang mit der
Staatsanwaltschaft mit den Einsätzen was
jetzt auch Polizei zu verantworten hat
werde ich und bin ich in ständigem
Austausch mit dem Landesbranddirektor
und der Polizeipräsidentin wir haben
auch heute Nachmittag wieder eine
schalte es läuft jetzt viel auch und der
Wahlkampf das muss ich ganz deutlich
sagen dass ärgert mich auch weil es wird
auch viel thematisiert was auch fehl
Einschätzungen hat wenn es heute zum
Beispiel so kommt dass das Waffenrecht
in Berlin schon hätte verändert werden
können dann ist das grober Unfug und das
hat die bundesinnenministerin gerade
gesagt es gibt Gesetze die können wir in
Berlin verändern
zum Beispiel wenn wir die
böllerverbotszonen ausweiten wollen und
es gibt oder die bodycams und dashcams
können wir schon einführen das können
wir in Berlin machen aber es gibt im
Bundesgesetze und da möchte ich als
Vorsitzende der Innenministerkonferenz
gemeinsam mit dem BMI gemeinsam mit der
bundesinnenministerin und mein
amtskolleginnen und Amtskollegen auch
natürlich an die Gesetze im Mund dran
aber es wird nicht alles über die
Innenminister über die insanatoren zu
lösen sein sondern hier ist der gesamte
Senat hier ist auch die Bundesregierung
gefordert entsprechende Maßnahmen
gemeinsam zu machen weil wir eben nicht
nur dieses Phänomen in Berlin haben auch
wenn von außen jetzt immer gerne auch
mal auf Berlin geschaut wird es ist
nicht nur in Berlin gewesen es war in
allen Großstädten der Fall dass wir
solche Vorkommnisse hatten das heißt wir
müssen uns um die jungen Leute die
diesen Respekt verloren haben dringenst
kümmern aber im übrigen auch um die
Eltern das heißt also wenn ich Eltern
habe die hier nur zu Duldungen in der
Stadt sind die eben nicht arbeiten
können die keinen Erwerb machen können
ja dann werden wir in Berlin auch die
Duldungen natürlich von denjenigen die
hier über viele Jahre schon sind dann
auch natürlich abschaffen das
Bundesrecht gibt es das bereits sehr und
das werden wir in Berlin machen ich
erwarte dass wir und das da bin ich in
ständigen Austausch in ständigen
Austausch mit der Polizeipräsidentin
dass wir jetzt die Auswertungen
an die Staatsanwaltschaft sehr zügig
rübergehen die Regierende
Bürgermeisterin hat es gesagt und wir
müssen mit der Justiz natürlich auch
überlegen welche weiteren Schritte sind
jetzt wirklich jugendstrafbarkeit sind
jetzt tatsächlich nötig das heißt also
es ist nicht nur eine Sache von Inneres
sondern es ist von uns allen und das ist
wichtig hier auch noch mal an der Stelle
deutlich zu sagen was Berlin machen kann
werden wir tun und was wir im Bund
machen können werden wir
selbstverständlich miteinander auch
unter den Innenministern dann
miteinander besprechen weil alle
Innenminister haben so ein Problem nicht
nur die Berliner in seiner Toren
herzlichen Dank